Hello,
my precious little ravioli.
I'm gonna show you
everything.
Let's go, butt-fuck.
Then there was Missy.
She was worm-squirming
to god-knows-who,
but she was doing it.
Missy! My gentle geranium.
This one is embarrassed that
his balls have yet to drop.
And this one
is a schemie little perv!
Do you think my name
is Shame Lizard?
Yeah! Cool name.
Michael Douglas.
My old sex friend
and current subordinate,
I wanna see you
in my office tonight, sir.
You've got the power now
Yeah! Lube her up!
Marty, it's us, Marty.
Have a taste.
You know you want us.
-Is anybody here?
-I'm here.
-What? Who are you?
-I'm you in the future.
Wait. What's future me
doing in the Alone Zone?
You live here.
-Come here. Yeah.
-Really?
-In front of... scorpion?
-Is that his name?
-I love it.
-Fuck, yeah, that's his name
and I love you.
How's those dicks hanging,
you tiny cracker honkies?
Oh! Holy Nyong'o!
I'm about to
Lupita my pants.
I'll tell you
what's gonna be hard.
The dossier says
we're working
with Coach Steve Steve.
You five people
came to the Diaper Barge
and jumped on me.
This is the best day
of my life, baby!
What kind of hormone
monster are you, man?
Making a kid feel bad
for jacking off.
That's against
the Jizzacratic Code.
What's up, Chuck.
Obviously, this is
your first time in a caff.
Smart guy.
It's Doubt!
A gut-wrenching drama
about child molestation
in the Catholic Church.
You're watching Doubt
and you're still horny?
This is madness.
Look at these two rascals.
I've named them
Zack and Cody
and think they're gonna have
a pretty sweet life.
Those are just
some of the infamous
and very hurtful things
that I'm thrilled to reveal
about Jay Bilzarian.
-I'm looking at you, Jay.
-Shit!
You're Helicobacter pylori
bacterium?
Which causes
acute gastritis.
Andrew! You're quite good
at Bacterium Delirium.
Well, I'm just happy
to be hereium.
Even though Dolf Lungren
played a Russian in Rocky IV
which I haven't
been allowed to see,
-but I did IMDB him...
-Oh, yeah.
...he's actually
from Sweden.
What a surprise
to see you guys here.
Come on.
Geometry!
Shake your booty
'cause it's time to...
Countdown
to Money with Nick Starr!
Also, bye!